(audience applauding)
- Red is my favorite color
to wear.
- Ooh.
- You're wearing my
favorite color to wear.
It's nice to see you.
I think you are hilarious.
You are so talented, so gifted.
Have you met Bonnie before?
- No, first time.
- Y'all never met before?
- Hello.
- Okay.
- You look gorgeous.
- Thank you.
- That was hilarious.
I loved "The Lost City."
We're gonna get to it.
That was so funny.
I love the movie.
But your parents were
both educators, right?
My mama was a teacher.
- Yeah.
Yeah.
- So growing up
with two of them.
- My mama
was a kindergarten teacher.
- Oh, I love that.
- Yeah.
- My mom was first grade.
- Like they're learning to read and yeah.
- Mm-hmm.
- That was so...
Was it hard having parents far,
like education-?
- Well,
education's everything.
- Yeah.
- So it's-
(audience applauding)
Thank you guys.
- But like, as an adult, we know that.
But as a kid, I was always
like, "I've got it."
- Yeah, yeah.
- Like with my homework, yeah.
- And then like you get home
and you have like the workbook.
- Yep.
- And your mom enforce summer school.
- Yeah, oh my God.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God, no.
- Like I never stayed at school
for more than like two or three years
'cause it wasn't good enough.
Like it was like-
- Oh my gosh.
(fingers clicking)
- You're going to another
school and another school.
So then college, I was like,
"Whoa, I'm in one place."
(both laughing)
I'm in one place.
- Oh my gosh, so you
moved around quite a bit?
- Yeah.
- I moved around a bit.
I feel like it kind of,
made me very outgoing.
- Yes.
- Do you feel like it did that
for you?
- Adaptability is key.
- Yeah.
- And then I feel like,
you got to understand who you were.
Like, I felt older.
Like I was more mature
because you had to learn
like what you're good at
'cause you needed a gimmick, right?
You had to like impress the
new kids with something.
So the next-
- I went with humor.
- Yes.
- I went with humor
- Humor, and I was like,
I could do a little
(Da'Vine squeaking)
a little bit, then I was like,
"Okay, that combo is
how you get the kids."
- Yeah, that's why, yeah.
I'd just bluff at me
before anyone else could.
I was like, I was very
defensive with my insecurity.
Did you move around ever
when you were a kid,
or did you stay in one place?
- We went from California to New York
if my dad had another Broadway Show.
So we were used to going back and forth.
- Oh, wow, right on that.
- And I didn't get a tan,
so I like these (mumbles).
(all laughing)
Yeah.
- So congrats on the new movie.
So "The Lost City" it's so funny.
Y'all we got slow clap,
that's why I call him today.
So tell everybody who you play in it?
- So I play Beth and Beth is
the publicist, best friend,
stylist, all the things
into one, two Loretta
who is Sandra Bullock's character.
And basically it's like loosely based off
of "Romancing the Stone".
- I thought that was
like those like Michaels-
it's in there.
- Turner.
Yeah.
- Yeah, it's in there.
And so I always say I'm
a Denny DeVito character.
(all laughing)
And so basically, I like
forced her to do this book
because she's recently had,
her husband has passed and
she's a little depressed
and I'm like, "Listen,
like you're really talented
"but this is gonna be the
thing that gets you out of it."
Like on the friend side of thing.
And the business side
of thing is I'm like,
"I need to make money.
"So you need to get out there"
- Get to work.
- And so she writes this book,
her husband was a archeologist.
And so she writes something
in the book that leads it
to believe that like, I don't
know, there's buried treasure
and so then Daniel
Radcliffe, AKA Harry Potter.
- Yeah.
- Plays the most amazing villain ever.
- Amazing.
- And I felt like when we were like-
- Like he might be a little psycho,
he's so good at it (laughs).
- You see this is what I think,
I think he was doing a good
job as being all sweet and nice
as Harry Potter and all
that stuff was built up.
(all laughing)
- That was the act.
- That's the real guy.
- And I was like, (squeaks).
You need to roll out.
- I'm here.
It's so funny.
I think it's different than
like "The Jewel of the Nile" and "Romancing The Stone"
but it's just in that vein
and I don't feel like
people are making those kind
of movies anymore and I love those.
- Yeah, you're getting like Indiana Jones-
- Yeah, you're getting all of it.
- You're getting all this stuff.
- Yeah.
- And I think that was the
biggest thing that surprised us,
we did not know how much
action it was gonna be.
We thought it was gonna be like CGI
but we just so happened to
be filling in DR and no.
- Yeah, it was (all laughing).
Wait (laughs) and no.
- No, no.
- Because I heard that
Daniel he was here recently
and he said that, he's in all these suits,
like in the Dominican
Republic and it's so hot.
- Yeah.
- And he like, literally was like
we're gonna have to make...
Like y'all were sweating to death.
Like.
- Yeah, well cause you know,
you're thinking, "At least I was."
I was like, "I wanna look amazing.
"I wanna be giving the people
looks on, looks on, looks.
(all laughing)
And then you get out there
and you're like, (nods)
"I should have just wore sun dress."
- Cause you have like cool
on you're covered too, yeah.
- I had a three piece suit.
- Oh ouch.
- Three piece suit.
- So he was complaining,
you had a suit too.
- Yeah.
- And I had a corset and a suit.
- I'm so glad I was
born now and not, yeah.
(audience laughing)
'Cause I-
- Elastic.
- I would not, elastic.
- Elastic, thank you.
- I'm into elastic.
I'm into yoga pants that
I've never done yoga in.
- Yeah.
(all laughing)
That's what I live in with my mom bun.